we have a voicemail number and that
number is 2192 david p so yesterday a
guy from alabama who said he doesn't
know a lot of jews
uh he called in and he wanted me to
explain yiddish words to him and the
questions were what is the dif what is
schmeckle and what's the difference
between schmeckle and sheckle now the
eggman called in the eggman is a jewish
man and the eggman says it's wrong that
asking me jewish questions
is like asking a black woman to touch
her hair i don't know if this analogy is
exactly right but let's listen to what
the eggman had to say
hey dave the caller on today's show was
a schmuck
without using any yiddish words and i'm
just kidding
i really can't stand when people say to
me hey man did you do this hey did you
believe this that's like going up to a
black woman and saying hey can i touch
your hair
i mean i get it like when i was in
prison i'd meet guys from the south that
would say you're a jew where are your
horns okay i get that but it's not 25
years ago and we have the internet in
modern times now so i find it highly
insulting and i go back to my original
comment that caller was a schmuck for
asking you to speak for the jewish
language or the hebrew language or the
yiddish language
shalom brother
yeah i don't know if i agree with the
egg man i mean like let's let's just
think it through
would it be crazy to think
let's imagine like a really spit what is
a schmeckle is is not exactly mainstream
it's not like hey do do jews uh believe
in the new testament and it's like no
okay so it's it's schmeckles it's pretty
pretty niche
let's say there was a discussion as to
which african countries were the main
sources of slaves brought to the united
states and let's say in a conversation
someone said oh did uh were there a lot
of american slaves that came from
the central african republic right
that's a really specific question i
don't know the answer to that
would it be wrong to wonder
if a black person in the group
might be more informed about that than i
am
i don't know i guess i'm not sure
i don't think the egg man is right that
asking me about yiddish words is the
same as asking to touch a black woman's
hair that there seems to be absolutely
no comparison there but is it reasonable
to wonder
whether based on an individual's
identity you might know more about a
particular thing i mean
you if you knew someone was a parent
i think it would be reasonable to go to
them with parenting questions over
someone who's not a parent
if you knew someone was tall
i don't think it's unreasonable to go to
them with questions about the day-to-day
of living while being tall
i i don't know i don't know that this is
that that crazy i think the real
critique is
you know about google right like if i
ever wonder about these questions you
just you just google it i don't know
that you need to leave me a voicemail
wait two weeks for me to get to that
voicemail and then give you an answer
but it is content so i don't know let me
know your thoughts we have an explosive
bonus show today there's not an
emergency blowout the way that alex
jones described earlier on the show but
we have a very explosive bonus show
today
a trump appointed judge has said
the cdc exceeded its um
jurisdiction
with the mask mandate on planes and the
judge ended the mask mandate on planes
yesterday pilots came out during flights
and announced to their uh passengers the
mask mandate is over they unmasked and
passengers cheered and unmasked and
immuno-compromised people on those
flights were horrified we're going to
talk about it we're going to talk about
it
also
j.d vance who i at one point thought hey
this is kind of like a reasonable
republican i was wrong
j.d vance who is running for the ohio
senate seat
has been endorsed by failed former
president donald trump we will talk
about jd vance
and thirdly elizabeth warren is now
targeting nancy pelosi
in a bid to avoid midterm losses for
democrats in november what
i will explain all of it to you on
today's bonus show you can access the
bonus show instantly by becoming a
member at joinpacman.com
absolute last thing it is finally that
day it's almost like christmas morning
for our christian viewers or
the fourth day of hanukkah for our
jewish years i always got the best gifts
on the fourth day that's why i was
always excited about day four um
it is the day of the david pakman show
town hall the town hall will be live
today tuesday april 19
6 p.m eastern time we will be streaming
live on the pacman live youtube channel
and if you'd like to call in you can do
so through our discord
davidpakman.com discord if you're a
member we will have a priority line for
you which is very exciting and just
another reason to get yourself that
membership at joinpacman.com
i will see everybody
on the bonus show today
on the town hall tonight or otherwise
sadly
tomorrow on the next show